canal+ créations originales 2016
libra surprenante forte
lemay télé pour savoir où vous êtes
tu vas entrer en guerre avec les turcs
c'est ça ouais enfin c'est comme des
flics
me fera pas tomber sur notre permission
c'est moi et moi seul qui décideraient
du jour de votre gloire
j'ai besoin d'une belle élection avec un
beau score qui marque les esprits
j'ai des tas contre moi on a parlé de se
laisser faire
j'ai fait une erreur une seule et depuis
je n'arrête pas d'essayer de la réparer
c'est par amour non vous êtes là pour
pouvoir de nouveau porter un masque
c'est pour ça que vous êtes dangereux
la criminelle attend votre retour car un
acte terroriste
c'est mon salaire
migaud
questionna
appartenant à son fils que jamais
prévisible
plus libre
plus surprenante
plus forte
toujours plus originales
canal+ créations originales